hey guys welcome back to another video
here on this channel and I can't I knew
it was coming guys but the day that the
patch came out for season 2 someone had
to look into the files and we found new
executions new emotes new effects and a
bunch of other things regarding the next
couple weeks hopefully the next couple
weeks of for honor someone looked
through they found some stuff as I
mentioned I just want to give a quick
shout out though 2x Dead ZX he was the
one that kind of found most of it and
put it on YouTube which is what I'll be
showing to you now just want to say a
big shout out to him leaves channel
description if you want to see any more
of his stuff he also does a few for on
our videos I just want to take the time
before I said before I play this video
to thank you all for the more recent
support in the past like 5 or 6 days I
made a video on the Dead stream when the
character is just released and I didn't
expect them to really do that well but
it was my most popular video that I've
ever made being like 36,000 views as I'm
looking at it right now so I'm
completely ecstatic like thank you guys
so much we've gained 50 60 subs in the
past like 4 days so thank you to all
that and hello to all the new people
that have joined here but anyway enough
shutting up
let me just shut up for a bit and I'll
let you guys watch these 2 videos so
I'll see you when these are over
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Hey
by
[Music]
[Music]
see guys those were the new executions
emotes and stuff that I mentioned
previously I'm not going to lie though
the law barring execution was pretty
nice with the whole choking the warlord
doing the WWE people's elbow that was
[ __ ] amazing and those effects men oh
my god the the Blackstone Knight the
Jade everything looks just amazing I
cannot wait for this to come out I don't
know when it's coming out though
hopefully it'll be in the next couple
weeks we can only hope maybe it won't be
till the end of the next season who
knows but just wanted to let you guys
know kind of show to you all and that'll
be it for the end of the today's video
guys if you did like this video please
be sure to subscribe and like this video
always just like I said subscribe to
keep up to date and so you never miss a
video that I come out with you can even
hit the bell icon on the top to get
notified when I come out videos so you
can be part of the notification squad
and I'll see you all tomorrow for the
dev stream recap video and peace out
guys see you later